au
[Musique]
revoir au sort pas trop je faisais ça va
être très content ce soir nicolas et
pimprenelle aussi oui mais pour juliette
1 j'ai quelque chose dans ma pâte
molle
[Musique]
ou mais oui la vie tient le voilà beau
soir
bonsoir
suis-je temps
mais oui ma belle je ne t'ai pas oubliée
tian an men en
saurez un bold adam tes copains tu à
présent les enfants je vous raconte une
histoire
stars défilent et plus
je me pose
écoute bien julietta vive les vacances
juillet la petite philippine
qu'est ce qu'il fit tu vois bien elle
joue sur la plage avec le lapin blanc et
tous les deux ensemble ils faisaient de
grands trous dans le sable que la mer en
montant remplissent d'eau je vais faire
des commissions dit la maman en fermant
la porte de la tente qui vient avec moi
philippines son seau à la main et le
lapin blanc le nez plein de sable partir
avec les acheteurs d'abord des fruits
chez le sweat yeux de la viande hachée
de la farine du riz du sud chine
épiciers du lait du beurre du fromage
chez le laitier et du pain chez le
boulanger
mais il y avait aussi dans la vitrine
une
magnifique à 1
et
dibi dibi dibi le lapin blanc la mange à
toute entière et se sauva
saga matar criait le boulanger attend
lapin attend pleurait philippines qui
avait peur de ne plus revoir son ami
aussi à la fin à la mais en revenant à
leurs maisons de toile la petite fille
retrouva le lapin blanc qui avait fort
mal à l'estomac i begin
du
tpiy est perdu
les philippines se mit à jouer du
tambour
[Musique]
car c'était la leçon que méritait ce
bouton
et voilà l'histoire est terminée elle
t'a plu juliette à eau
elle dort elle fait semblant est déjà
parti elle est rattachée nationale je
veux sauve les enfants allez vous
coucher tout seul
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah voici notre lapin blanc l'ont pas
trop je ne suis pas glouton moi c'est
vrai nounours oh commun on y va oui en
route bonne nuit des enfants fait de
pour eux
[Musique]
oh
où